as a fourth line Winger for the Kraken Andre
barovsky returns he's been out the last month
and a half with an upper body injury 12 10 and one
they've won for their last five they got the Jack
Hughes line out there and he snaps one from the
tough angle at guau nemit races back to hold it
in play around to Tooley for Hughes and a shot
went wide and cared off Jamie alexc seen pass
back for Hughes moving in and brow makes the stop
in the Hughes line busy early on they've won four
their last five rer Evans off to the wing in his
NHL debut got it to Tai cier from a sharp angle in
which they have not even held a lead during that
time over the last two weeks it's done fires it
on at tiira Schmidt from out High Banks it out
toward the Seattle L 6 minutes gone by on the
reload here's Ellie tolin ing on Ned looking for
a tip from Yanni gour Dunn wanted a high stick
there he thought he got one from Jack Hughes and
no call wer fires high off the Ricochet barowski
to the slot and Schmid covers up 112 points last
year a trip to the second round and the high
expectations of this season Alexia Fir and on net
kicked out by Aira Schmid 33 points in 18 games
to holey spins off es skate picked up by Miller
throws it on Ned right into the globe of Philip
rubal coming off the Hughes Bowl against Quinn
and the Canucks in a 65 New Jersey Win Luke from
out high and it saved by gral walking down the
wall in the waiting seconds palot spins it back
turns it over done out of the boxes the cracking
the race up ice moving in here's a shot for smid
makes the stop pulls up waits for reinforcements
works it back to the line here's toing in with
a shot bed out in front toward buters trying to
kick at it and covered by Schmid over right back
in with Meyer here's Teo Meyer swooping in behind
working it toward the front of the net Mercer out
in front couldn't locate it in time and shipped
out by Oliver borran and it lived up to it what
a thrilling game that was with cut of action 11
combined goals in that 65 win Jasper brat the hero
in the final minute heer lcks one across back out
in front they score it's Andre palot and the devil
grab the lead on the road in the first in Seattle
here has to go to the New Jersey Devil sports line
they created the icing they got Seattle Kraken
players on the ice that are tired it allows the
niker line to come out and push back they have
a quick neutral zone regroup they go right back
at them don't allow them to change and look two
guys wide open in front of the net if it wasn't
going to be Pat you know he's really smooth with
the puck very confident he had a tough giveaway
the other night but seemed to rebound quickly
after that you know he's going to make mistakes
g a shot went wi of the net and that's an example
of it there it just kind of caught who do I have
the guy in the corner the guy in the front and he
stands in the middle at some point you just got
to be a little aggressive nemes on that play and
that'll come with the maturity Hughes pulled up
played it for Luke Hughes and now Jared mccan
carries up ice for the Kraken he's got Everly
with him Everly trying to settle down a bouncing
p m nearly went Airborne over the top of Akira
Schmid coming off two goals Tuesday worked at
net front now back to the line for Luke Hughes
back for Brett connects with Hughes straight on
moved into the circle Miller brang it off the
iron here's the Miller chance as he jumps up
the play you can see the way grow read Yanni
gourd's line is out there as it often is for
Dave haxall to start the second he told in off
to the wing Larsson loads one up and cought
off by Aira Schmid he gets it deep all the
way around for Tyler to Foley from no angle
off the side of the net bouncing down Hollow
with a backand turned aside the rebound nearly
went for toley plays it around for Luke Hughes
out High walking the line fire a one-time
kicked out Miller back door spraing out
Kow fire cut off Everly and K on the
reload here's Mercer moving in with a
shot and that save grow and rims it around
cut off there by Marino and guided off by
grout a fly fighting for that pass twoes out
toward mccan he Lumbers up ice and gains entry
verovski shielding back for the first time
in a month and a half played only six games
early on dun beted across the shot save SCH
smid on for akowski loose in front and Chip
High Tyler Yamamoto breaks it up on a pass
intended for Luke Hughes at the point off
to the wing tie K fires on net and loved by
Akira Schmid pulled up at the wall met there
by the Long Reach of lson and now mccan BS
for burkovski who couldn't elude Kevin Ball
jabbed along for Marino picked up by wber to
the slot they score Ty K time this game and
one get some speed and you get some energy
back and you get a guy that's good when he's
first in on the for check you can see
he loses the puck here but stays with
it creates some pressure creates a turnover
by the New Jersey defenseman ball and that
allows wenberg to come in and Tai car has
been all over it tonight this is about a
six shot on net here in the second and the
great work of Andre Bur kovski plays a part
in that now moving in it's Hollow in the
shot and grow fights that off Lees it for
the Speedy McLoud always playing at 100 milph
pitched around by dein Shore just back from the
AHL below the goal line worked out in front for
nemes they score Shamone nemit his first in the
NHL gives the Devils the lead again well it just
starts a battle down low for the New Jersey Devils
in the Kraken Zone you can see all the pressure
coming but watch nemit he's in the middle in the
neutral zone and watch him just slide down in
a perfect timing in a perfect place and what a
finish for his first National Hockey League
ball and that's the offensive Instinct that
the New Jersey Devils are going to get from this
young man D plays off to Evans touch on by mccan
here's wber to the forand what a stop by smid
by Jared mccan for Alex wber now rink wide feed
for rer Evans a dynamic skater he snaps one
on how about Yamamoto 36 seconds on average
in with the Oilers on the power play here with
the Kraken 246 up a one timer there he circles
back into his own end toward the 19-year-old
nemes couldn't locate it Everly moves in a
shot to the sharp angle short side dun stops
on a dime on Mercer dun works it to the goal
line then across for baners who couldn't get
the shot off cleanly smid makes the save on
thecan and as Seattle gets a ton of chancees just
a turnover by merer you had an opportunity to get
it out prer see if it comes back to Han out in
front wedberg is denied by Schmid across the
crease and another save by Schmid by Schmid as
New Jersey was on their heels here's some early
chances wber gets a point blank opportunity a
nice glove kept it alive for Luke Hughes it's
checked there by mccan goes through the slot
and here's a two onone it's McAn with gour
mccan shoots and rag it up the post but it's an
absolute rocket from Jared mccan as they create
a two onone you knew they were going to push
on the offensive side of things being down not
only a man but in this hockey game and I mean
Schmid is going to thank that crossbar tonight
when he goes to sleep look at that held in
by Bor strand mve for Dawn toward the net
off a body in front final 4 seconds loose to
the side of Schmid jabed that jabed that and
horns the Devils get the job done in Seattle